the ocean is facing environmental
catastrophe you know really we are
facing a planetary emergency these
ecosystems are disappearing overfishing
is a ticking time bomb for both planet
and people hundreds of millions of
people depend on tropical and
small-scale fisheries for their survival
and these fisheries are collapsing in
one remote coastal village the locals
appear to have found an unlikely
solution affirmative Ottumwa Audrey said
I'm elected as a liberal a strange
little sea creature that's a popular
aphrodisiac and just possibly a
fisherman's salvation
in the first business of its kind in
Madagascar do Dini has recently started
farming these animals sea cucumbers well
Sharon good kidney sea cucumbers are
under threat growing them in designated
and contained areas is helping to
protect both this important species and
other kinds of marine life here in the
southwest of Madagascar feasel twins
wanted latina for families hi
say para sangria PR because of the part
sea cucumbers play in cleaning up the
seabed it's believed that they help
maintain stocks of other marine life
they're not the most charismatic of
animals but they play an enormous ly
important role in eating the sediment
that the detritus the organic material
that surrounds every single grain of
sand and the algae that will grow around
those grains in this region not just sea
cucumbers but all kinds of marine life
have suffered from chronic overfishing
when marine conservationist Alastair
Harris first visited Madagascar in 2001
he was shocked to discover the extent of
this devastation we found some
anthropological research from the 80s
that shows that back then fishermen and
women will be able to fill the body of
an entire canoe in just a few hours
today that would be unimaginable
we saw ecosystems that had degraded to
the point where they were totally
unrecognizable largely because of
overfishing to reduce this overfishing
the NGO that alistair runs helped train
700 local fishermen and women in
small-scale sustainable sea cucumber
farming it's meant many locals are no
longer using the techniques that
contributed to overfishing in this
region allister's research suggests fish
stocks have doubled here since 2006 sea
fishes anga new Tromso latina Mahina -
Lumina Wasserman Umberto Foggia Mandar
oh man germany betray me - if Michigan -
news anchor so Tina Fey tamesha's - my
friends in Des Moines Iowa
but it is not marine conservation that
has fundamentally persuaded the local
population to buy into agriculture it's
hard economics
ultimately to help the marine
environment we have to help the
communities and the people that depend
on it there's a strong demand for sea
cucumbers in Asia where their prized as
an aphrodisiac farmers here can now make
up to $50 a month about twice that of a
regular fishermen well this is still
substantially below the average global
wage it's brought dramatic improvements
in the local quality of life Tanana and
Xango mark to focus in hands why mrs.
Amelia hombre sesame on boots
Chow says muharram fiddly group a rake a
battery yeah be napur no booty an Akita
no kombu las immunity lab to a mannequin
physically she broke a toad a leaf in
demand the vaadwaur Telesis cameroon
braces in magnitude er
NGOs including allister's are now
working on similar farming ventures in
other coastal villages around Madagascar
localized efforts can only go so far
encountering the vast damage to
ecosystems across the ocean but in the
face of an increasingly urgent crisis
that could still be a very long way
we've seen how viral scaling of
community-based marine conservation
initiatives can work and we are not
doing enough to amplify community
initiatives like these hundreds of
millions of people depend on tropical
so-called small-scale fisheries for
their survival and these fisheries are
collapsing across the Indian Ocean the
Pacific in the Atlantic we urgently need
replicable solutions that can have to
amplify lunges that these communities
face
[Music]
[Music]